and so my dad i'd like gotten out of the
shower and my dad was like hey there's a
tornado coming and you know we get
tornadoes all the time in oklahoma you
don't think really anything of it you're
just like okay you know i gotta go take
shelter there's a tornado coming i just
ripped like right through where my high
school was the neighborhood to the south
that lived it ripped like right where we
lived which is right across the street
from the high school but yeah it was
pretty traumatizing at the time there
were like four people where we lived in
that vicinity that died and and so i
mean i just felt like this appreciation
for like i'm alive like i can still run
i still have my running talent and and
and it kind of like made me like become
more spiritual with myself and i felt
like and like i started running long on
sunday as a way to like celebrate my
life and like my running talent it kind
of put me back in touch with my myself
and like being appreciative of my life
so